in political debates it's easy to fall
into abstractions to think of Politics
as simply a matter of ideas floating in
The Ether rather than as real policies
that affect real people this is
especially true when we talk about
transiting the kids which is a very
popular topic of discussion on both
sides of the aisle the whole thing is so
bizarre most people have no idea what it
looks like in practice
this is what it looks like this is what
giving a 16 year old girl testosterone
looks like
so I got out of my haircut
um because my hair was driving me nuts
and I shaved it because I'm tired of
watching my hair thin out and it's less
distressing if I shave it so when I talk
about being too far gone not I don't
really know what else to call it
um this is what I mean this is how deep
my voice is
um it's gotten deeper over time and it's
settled
um this is what I mean by hair loss and
it just keeps getting worse it keeps
thinning it keeps receding backwards
um
you know and I'm not exactly sure that's
coming back
um those are the main things when I talk
about being androgenized
um to a point of no return
um I really don't see those being
fixable
so that's when I talk about you know
just kind of staying how I am regardless
of how I feel
um that's why just because I I don't
really see me personally being able to
come back from what's happened so far so
I hope that's a little explanatory
your heart just breaks for this girl
and it breaks Because deep down you know
that she's right
there is no way to undo the damage
inflicted on her body by the adults who
mutilated her body
I'm not saying that all hope is lost it
isn't I'm not saying that she can't live
a wonderful life she certainly can but
something really was taken from her by
every adult who should have known better
and who allowed this to happen from her
immediate family all the way up to
President Biden who pushes the stuff at
the federal level okay something was
really taken from her and we we labor
under this delusion in Modern Life that
nothing's permanent everything's
reversible there's no all of your
commitments all of your obligations all
of your decisions about your own body
and your life none of it's permanent you
can just change whatever but that's not
true that there is a lot of irreversible
damage that came as a result of this
transgender insanity this fad that's
going to pass but the damage is not
going to pass you'll notice the left
never promotes these videos
the left never shows you mutilated kids
or forget about transgenderism for a
second left never shows you dying babies
in the womb the left never shows you
crime in the Border towns that the left
never shows you addicts who overdose on
drugs the left never shows you any of
the actual effects of their policies
the left does the opposite the left
relies on euphemisms that's what
political correctness is vague words
intended to hide harsh realities
intended to deceive
that distinction tells you everything
you need to know about American politics
in 2022 in order for the Left To Win It
needs to hide the reality of what it is
doing in order for the right to win it
just needs to convince people to open
their eyes these politicians these
Democrats look really really bad there's
a Louisiana Democrat who's running for
congress who just released an ad focused
largely on defending abortion
in the ad there is a video of her
actually giving birth to her son
I'm Katie darling and I live on a farm
in St Tammany Parish
our family compost collects rain water
and grows our own food
my husband and daughter helped take care
of the chickens
and there's someone else who's going to
be joining us and helping to pitch in
with Farm Life very soon
but these days I worry about storms that
are stronger and more frequent because
of climate change
about our kids underperforming Public
Schools and about Louisiana's new
abortion ban one of the strictest and
most severe in the country
[Music]
putting pregnant women at ease now
putting their lives at risk
I haven't spent my career in Washington
I've worked my way up from bartender to
CEO
now I help nurses organize our
complicated health records
because nurses aren't just Heroes
they're Saints
Louisiana deserves better than the path
we're on
I'm Katie darling and I'm running for
congress because I want that better path
for you for her and here we go
for him
that is the most psychotic ad not forget
even psychotic it's the most
Psychopathic political ad I have ever
seen in my in my entire life excuse me I
wasn't getting choked up I just hiccuped
but I could be getting choked up that is
absolutely
psycho
one if you if you run for office at all
you're you have at least a 15 chance of
being a psychopath just generally in
either party
then if you invite a political film crew
in to roll tape while you're giving
birth you have a 99.7 chance of being a
stone cold psychopath and then if you
can hold your newborn baby boy and look
into the camera
and
celebrate the right to dash his brains
out to that's actually not what happens
in an abortion if you would defend the
right to uh poison him and then
dismember him this little newborn baby
that you are holding in your hands that
the legal right to rip that baby limb
from limb not five seconds before that
ad could have been filmed
you have a one
100 chance of being a psychopath which
this woman obviously is and it got me
thinking why the hell would she ever air
this she looks nuts she looks like a
stone cold killer
and I suspect the thinking here was
to try to to try to split the baby on
the issue because Louisiana is a largely
pro-life state
she's running as a Democrat and so she
doesn't want to seem completely cold in
callous like the infanticidal maniac
that she is so she says okay what I'm
going to do is with my words I'm going
to defend abortion
and then in my actions I'm going to seem
like a loving mother and so I'm going to
appeal to both people the kind of
traditional voters and also the psychos
who want to kill all the babies and for
me at least probably for you
the effect of that is the opposite she
just looks like Lady Macbeth out damn
spot you know dashing her baby's brains
out
but I suspect that was a little bit of
the thinking there
the other really telling thing here is
everyone in in the
in the ad is seen every subject of the
ad is seen the husband gets a lot of
face time the little little daughter
gets a lot of Face Time the candidate
obviously gets a lot of Face Time the
only person who we we see a little bit
of of the person's back but we never see
the person's face is the newborn baby
and now this I think ties right in with
what we were talking about at the top
it's very hard
to support abortion if you see a little
baby
and newborn babies are cute their faces
are all kind of smushy and cute you know
so you would think in a political ad if
you're if you're Stone Cold psycho
enough to put your birth in a political
ad you want the cutest part of the whole
scene in the ad right the most appealing
attractive part but she can put the
baby's face in the ad
for the same reason that the libs can't
show you the the actual transgendered
kids
who have had their bodies mutilated for
the same reason they can't show you the
actual border towns where all of those
illegal aliens show up for the same
reason
that they can't show you all of the
overdose victims of their drug policies
they can't show you the reality of the
policies that they are advocating the
rest of the show is continuing now in
the members block it is work Wednesday
and so my producer Ben Davies has teed
up a new challenge for me it is from the
channel love don't judge and the
challenge is to see how long I can just
totally simply merely love without any
kind of judgments whatsoever creeping
into my head I'm not sure how long I'm
going to make it if you are not a member
click the link in the description and
join us we will see you on the member
block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]